all the letters are there except for the
s in fresh and here's what happens solve
it or spin it or but do something
quickly okay
okay what letter for you I'll go with a
G
I think the internet age makes it not
worth it to go on Wheel of Fortune and I
don't I don't say this to just wait look
I'm a fan of Wheel of Fortune in
Jeopardy I would never go on these shows
anymore look I watched Jeopardy and I
will kill that show I I will absolutely
kill it my best games on Jeopardy are
when I'm totally alone in the living
room and no one is there to hear me
answering the questions correctly and
then I'll have to go tell my wife about
it and she won't care at all